so let's start with three points point a
point B point B and Point C and if we
connect these three points these three
different points with and there they are
not collinear they are not on the same
line if I connect them with line
segments I will get ours I will get a
triangle and I think you're familiar
with the idea of a triangle
and what I want to do in this video is
prove that the angles inside a triangle
sum up to 180 degrees so if this is if
the measure of this angle is a measure
of this angle is B measure of this angle
is C and I use lowercase a B and C
actually let me not use those since I've
already used a B and C if this was x y&z
I'm going to prove that X plus y plus Z
is going to be equal to 180 degrees now
let me get those out of the way so that
we clear up some space for the actual
proof so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to start off by constructing a line that
is parallel to line segment BC but it
goes through point a so that line might
look something like this
that line might look something like that
and I could call that line L and let me
continue this this line segment BC let
me just turn it into a line just so it
looks like a nice just so it looks like
a nice line so that we see that they
really are parallel lines parallel lines
and let me show you that they are
parallel and so and so I could write
here I could say line L I'm going to
assume I've constructed line L in a way
that it is parallel to line to line BC
it is parallel to line BC and the reason
why I do that is then all of a sudden
the two other sides of the triangle
become transversals for these two
parallel lines they intersect those two
parallel lines and in case you're
wondering hey Hatzalah how did you how
did you just assume that you can
construct a parallel line here you can
always given one line and you find a
point that's off of that line there's
always a unique parallel line that goes
through that point that's not on the
original line and I think you could see
that just by kind of reasoning it out or
kind
just visually looking at things so what
I want to do is start to think of line
segment a-b and line segment AC as
transversals of those two parallel lines
so let me just continue them on so they
look like real lines and not just line
segments so that's that is line a B that
is one transversal and then I have line
AC that just keeps going so I'm
continuing this side right over here
that is another transversal so line AC
is another transversal it intersects the
two parallel lines so now let's think
about some of the angles inside the
triangle so let's say that the measure
of this angle right over here let's say
the measure of that angle is X well we
know from what we've learned about
parallel lines that there this is this
is one angle between the transversal and
one of the parallel lines and there's a
corresponding angle between that same
transversal and the other parallel line
and it is sitting right over here we
know that the corresponding angles are
equal if this has measure X then that is
measure X if this is 30 degrees and that
is 30 degrees if this is 70 degrees then
that up there is also 70 degrees well we
also know we also know that if that is X
then the vertical angle is also going to
be X so this is also going to be X fair
enough now let's think about another
angle in the Triangle let's say that the
measure let's say the measure of this
angle right over here is going to be Y
so if this angle right over here is
going to be Y what is this entire angle
what is this entire angle going to be
well it's going to be X plus y this
entire angle is X plus y well if this
entire angle that I've kind of this arc
in green I've shown you if that's X plus
y let me write it over here that is X
plus y I'm talking about this whole
thing this whole thing is going to be X
plus y cos x and y or adjacent right
there they shared this side then does
this whole X plus y have any
corresponding angles if we look at this
transversal if we look at transversal AC
well sure it has a corresponding angle
right over here
if this angle is X plus y and I maybe
I'll draw that as a little bit neater if
this angle right over here is X plus y
then this angle right over there is X
plus y now if this angle is X plus y
what is let me do this in a new color
what is this angle right over here well
this angle this angle that's that's at
this intersection this angle X plus y
this green arc right over here is
supplementary to this magenta angle
right over here so we have X plus y let
me do it in that same green color you
can follow along so we'd have X plus y
plus question mark plus question mark is
going to be equal to 180 degrees their
outer sides form a straight angle they
are supplementary they're adjacent
angles whose outer sides form a straight
angle they're going to add up to 180
degrees and so the question mark angle
if we subtract X plus y from both sides
question mark is going to be equal to
180 minus X minus X minus y so this is
going to be equal to 180 minus X minus y
so now given how we've set up these the
three angles or the measures of the
three angles in the triangle what are
they add up to well let's add them up we
have X here that's one of the that's one
of the angles or I guess we can see the
interior angles in our triangle we have
X there then you have Y there X plus y
and then you have this character right
over here this character we figured out
is going to be 180 minus X minus y so
what are they going to add up to well
this X is going to cancel with this X
and then you have this Y is going to
cancel with this Y and you're going to
see that they add up exactly to 180
degrees so we just proved ourselves just
using what we know about parallel lines
that the angles the interior angles of a
triangle of any triangle add up to 180
degrees